Hey everybody and welcome back to the
channel. Um, so if you've been following
up with uh current events in my life, I
have recently left Google and I'm
actually doing some traveling. I'm in
Amsterdam, hence the change of scenery
here. Um,
for those of you who are wondering why
I'm not able to post more often than one
time a week, I'm probably spending about
22 hours a day and hence I'm a little
bit distracted. You know, I've been
considering front-end development more
so than distributed systems in the past,
you know, couple weeks. But for what
it's worth, I'm still trying to get
things out every once in a while, like I
mentioned, and this will probably be the
case for the next two-ish months. But
obviously, I'm still going to post
videos whenever I can. So, today we are
going to be covering two-phase locking.
So, let's go ahead and get into it.
Okay, I've got the iPad out, so let's go
ahead and get started. So, the subject
of today's video is two-phase locking.
So two-phase locking is just another
method of achieving isolation or
serializability, which effectively just
means that when we have a bunch of
transactions going on concurrently
within our database, it seems as if they
were just running one at a time. So in
our last video, we kind of discussed how
we would do this by literally running
them one at a time in terms of actual
serial execution. However, for today,
we're going to figure out a better way
of doing that by using a bunch of
locking. So let's go ahead and get
started. Typically, two-phase locking is
something that has been used in the past
because actual serial execution wasn't
feasible. CPUs weren't fast enough. And
so, you'll see this in a lot of
traditional SQL databases. Okay. So, the
thing that we're going to start out with
as follows. As you can see, I have
myself a row right here. You know, we
can go ahead and draw it out. And
imagine that the columns of this row are
basically my name and a shopping cart of
items that I want to purchase. And it's
got a corresponding lock. So basically
in the past, at least in my race
condition videos, what I've kind of
spoken about is locks basically means
exclusive access to this piece of data,
right? I couldn't read a row unless I
grabbed the lock. I couldn't write a row
unless I also grab the lock. So now what
we've got is this concept of basically
two-phase locking where instead of just
being a lock is enabling you exclusive
access to the row itself, you may
actually have a concept of shared
access. So in two-phase locking,
basically what we've got is the
following. We have a reader lock and
also a writer lock. So consider them the
same lock, but basically it's got two
modes. So if we want to go ahead and
read this row, what I can do is go ahead
and grab the lock right here in reader
mode. And basically, if I want to then
write to it, I would have to upgrade
that to a writer mode. But the kind of
trick here is that multiple threads or
multiple transactions can be reading a
row, but effectively in order to write
to that row, you have to be the only one
grabbing a lock. So you need to wait for
all of those readers to leave and then
upgrade your access to exclusive. So
basically the reason this works is that
for something like a read modify update
cycle which is basically the cause of
many different race conditions within
databases we know that our predicate aka
the read is always going to remain valid
because of the fact that whatever rows
we're reading in our predicate can't be
modified because no one is going to be
able to upgrade to get the writer lock
because we're concurrently reading them.
So again it means the predicate is
valid. Hence, this two-phase locking
approach actually works. So, what is a
big issue that we have to work with
here, and I'm going to circle this over
and over and over again because it's the
most important thing when it comes to
two-phase locking is deadlocks. So,
let's go ahead and show a diagram of how
this might happen. Because you might say
to yourself, "Oh, well Jordan, well, if
everyone grabs the resources in the same
order, it's impossible to have
deadlocks, right?" Well, no, that's not
necessarily the case. So, let's imagine
that if I put a square on a lock, that
means I'm grabbing it in reader mode.
And if I put a circle on the lock, I'm
grabbing it in writer mode. So,
basically, again, I'm doing the name
shopping cart example. Again, we've got
Jordan and Snoop Dogg. Two very re
realistic shopping carts for the both of
us. So, let's go ahead and get started.
Let's imagine that myself and Snoop Dogg
look at each other's shopping carts and
we say, "Oh, shoot. You know what? I
like those items that they have. Let's
go ahead and add those to ourselves."
So, what we're both going to do is read
each other's shopping cart and then
basically take all those items and add
them to our own. So, what that first
entails is let's imagine now that this
is the Jordan transaction, right? So,
first Jordan aka myself is going to grab
the reader lock for the Jordan lock.
It's going to grab the reader lock for
the Snoop Dog because I need to be able
to read a list in order to modify it.
And similarly, I need to be able to read
the Snoop Dogg row in order to
eventually get the items from it so I
can add them to my cart. And then
similarly, Snoop Dogg, which is
executing at the same exact time, he's
going to grab the reader lock for
himself, and he's also going to grab the
reader lock for Jordan, right? Because
we're both reading both our own and the
other person's shopping cart in order to
eventually make this update. So now,
what we would want to do is try and grab
the writer lock, right? But I've told
you earlier that you can't grab a writer
lock unless you are the only person
that's trying to write that row. Right?
If I were to put a circle here, that
would be bad. It would break the
invariant that, you know, a writer lock
needs to be exclusive. So, what we have
here is a deadlock. I can't complete my
right until Snoop Dogg completes his
right. And he can't complete his right
until I've completed my right. So, we
have a deadlock. And what that means is
that basically we need to go ahead and
avoid those somehow. So, the issue with
deadlocks is that it makes two-phase
locking slow. The reason for this being
that there are a bunch of deadlocks like
I've just described, and the system
effectively has to detect them and abort
them, right? It's going to have to go
back. It's going to have to cancel one
of the transactions that's part of the
deadlock and then run them again. So,
basically, in order for this to work,
you know, Snoop Dogg, I would have to go
ahead and pause this. I would have to
run Jordan to completion. And, you know,
once that's done, then I can run the
Snoop Dogg transaction.
So obviously that is going to take quite
a bit longer. We're no longer running
them concurrently and that's a problem.
Okay. And then in addition to basically
deadlocks which are a big problem with
two-phase locking. It takes a lot of
resources to grab the locks. So that's
slow too. And everything is defensive as
well. You know, we're grabbing locks
when we don't even necessarily need
them. We didn't even necessarily cover
all of our race conditions. Still, our
system here is not perfect. So let's
remind ourselves about phantoms. I
covered these I think two videos ago,
but basically uh phantoms are when you
do a read modify update cycle and the
update part is actually adding new rows
to your table. So in this case basically
let's imagine that uh you know a phantom
example would be this. My friend and I
both want to join a class with an
enrollment capacity of three. So let's
imagine that class is the flexibility
class at 6 p.m. So it's going to be
these two rows right here which I put
X's in front of. And right now there are
already two people in it. So we would
run the following SQL query on the right
over here put an arrow over there and
we'd basically say you know select all
the count uh from the classes basically
let's imagine the table name is classes
where the class name is flexibility and
the class time is 6:00. I personally
would like to get more flexible for
reasons I don't want to talk about. And
so basically the issue now is that
what's going to end up happening is that
we're both going to write rows to this
table, you know, with myself and then
him over here with my friend, Jordan's
friend. And so now there are four people
in the class. Why are there four people
in the class? Because these rows didn't
even exist yet. So we couldn't put locks
on them to prohibit each other from
writing. All we did was both grab the
reader locks
like so, like we saw just before. And
then we were both able to make a right.
There was nothing prohibiting us because
again, there's no locks to be had on
these two rows that don't yet exist. So,
like I say over here, we need to be able
to lock rows that don't even exist yet.
So, how can we fix this? Well, there's
something known as predicate locks. So
predicate locks are basically allowing
us in certain databases to grab all rows
that fit certain conditions. So in this
case, you know, I wanted to get my
predicate by figuring out all the rows
where the class name was flexibility and
the class time was 6:00. So in the case
of a predicate lock query, I would say
to myself, well, okay, I know that this
is kind of the predicate I want to put a
lock on. So before I actually make my
write, please put a lock on all of the
rows where the class name is flexibility
and the class time is 6:00. And that way
if the row doesn't even exist yet, it
would still have a lock on it because it
fits those parameters. That being said,
the issue with predicate locks is that
they're slow to run. We have to evaluate
this entire query where class name is
flexibility, class time is 6:00, and if
there's not necessarily an index that
perfectly corresponds with this query,
this could be very slow to run and
evaluate. So, what we move on to then is
the last part of this lesson called
index range locking. I basically already
described this predicate lock where I
would go ahead and search out these two
rows in the table and lock them. But the
issue with that is it takes a while.
Why? Well, let's imagine we have this
table right here where we have an index
on the class name field, but we don't
have an index on the class time field.
The index is indicated by this asterisk
here. So, because class time is not
necessarily organized in a linear
manner, it's not going to be easy to
find these two rows. But what is really
easy is if we just search by class name
because there's an index on class name
and that means that everything is sorted
that way. So what we could actually do
instead is simply grab the lock for all
the rows in flexibility because it's
really easy to find all the flexibility
classes in O of login time simply by
virtue of the fact that uh there is an
index on that field. And so now we can
go ahead and lock more rows than we
actually need to because it's a little
bit faster to run that query. This does
come with the one disadvantage of the
fact that well now if we're locking more
rows than we necessarily need to it's
possible that other queries that didn't
have to be blocked are now going to be
blocked. So you want to be careful about
doing this right you wouldn't want to
lock the whole table for example just to
run a very small query because then
we're going to be blocking all
transactions. So, it's a delicate
balance, but the point is, you know, if
you have to run a super in-depth query,
sometimes it's better to actually just
lock a supererset of the rows, right?
Where you're actually locking more than
necessary because running the query to
figure out which rows to lock is a
little bit faster. Okay guys, I hope
that makes sense and as always, hope you
have a great day. I will see you in the
next